I was gonna tell you what I did this
weekend I hope not a couple of my
friends and I were all theater buddies
and there's no theater right now so you
acted out a play with each announcer we
all watched the same play and then we
had a theater Club meeting and so we all
picked a play and it was Frankenstein
with the two different performances
between Jonny Lee Miller and Benedict
Gumpert Cumberbatch and and then we got
together to talk about it I'm laughing
at your excitement over it we had a
fantastic time let me look at you don't
even say I think I'd rather have
coronavirus than join a theater well we
were sick of our meetings always
descending into politics and all of that
stuff so it was my invention I thought I
saw those two plays and I said I got to
do this yeah and they loved it what are
you drinking chocolate milk no it's
coffee that's coffee but how much milk
do you have in that chocolate shake show
me that glass I want to see it look at
the color of that coffee I should have
brought it in a cup that you couldn't
see hold it up now I'm holding it up too
to the camera oh my god oh my god Robin
is reading a cup of chocolate I think
well I will say this I'm happy to see
that you're putting the coffee in the
right hand the fact that you're drinking
it rather than pouring it into your
[ __ ] is the big improvement what I
would call what you are drinking is milk
with a splash of coffee okay call it
what you like and coffee in there then
milk
Robin drinks milk with a spritz of
coffee I'm saying that is that coffee
even hot Robin that you're drinking no
it's not
because this is a thermal cup to keep it
hot mm-hmm look at you with your thermal
cop in your group
everything you do is fascinating
you